you took a pawn and now ariane just
trying to trade off queens very logical
not quite brave that moving as well i
mean you have to just calculate a little
bit because you're allowing well you're
allowing one check
so that's about the best i think that
white can get here
i mean one important line maybe we could
show it is if the white queen now moves
over to a very dangerous looking square
it didn't do it but if it comes to the
open file uh threatening check mate
black has to exchange off queens here uh
but this this would win the game and
yeah swap queens and win and okay we see
a result because here ariana has double
attacked he's uh sorry he's attacked the
white king and the white rook and this
ends the game i think vidit is about to
resign and we have a result yeah
actually frustrated in this game this
was his reaction when we actually
entered the game did he at some point
blunder here he did i think it was a few
mistakes here and there a few small
mistakes but those added up to the
eventual defeat for vidit and it was
just a race of attacks his attack was
too slow aryan's attack got there first
and he knows of course the tournament
situation a lot